bienvenue à tous pour jour emmanuel mais
j'ai aimé lui ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo votre rendez vous d'info du
week-end retour en 45 minutes sur tous
les temps forts qui ont marqué la
semaine politique
avec une mobilisation réussie pour les
syndicats jeudi il y avait plus de monde
dans les cortèges que le 19 janvier
dernier
pour autant le gouvernement ne lâche
rien est ce que cela va aggraver la
crise sociale c'est toute la question
en tout cas les réponses à apporter à la
crise divise à la majorité l'ump pierre
méhaignerie a joué les rebelles cette
semaine en proposant de remettre en
cause le principe du bouclier fiscal on
y reviendra
et puis c'est un grand changement de cap
pour la politique étrangère française
la france est pleinement de retour dans
l'otan c'est l'autre temps fort de ces
derniers jours députés et sénateurs en
ont débattu dans leur hémicycle
respectives des sujets dont on va parler
emmanuel dans cette émission avec un
eurodéputé évidemment très à l'aise sur
les plateaux de télé oui notre invité un
homme de médias qui s'est ancrée dans la
politique avec un horizon plus large que
l'exeo sur le point de dire canayer si
vous le pensez
jean marie cavada bonjour je vous
remercie d'être sur ce plateau depuis
2004 vous êtes parlementaires européens
et vous allez être sur le chef de file
pour le nouveau centre sur la liste ump
de la région ile-de-france ump donc
nouveau centre lors des prochaines
européennes en juin prochain
alors après quelques décennies dans
l'audiovisuel est la carrière que l'on
sait vous avez d'abord partagé en
politique les combats de françois bayrou
jusqu'à la présidentielle
et puis l'an dernier ça a été la rupture
vous êtes rapprocher de l'ump pour les
municipales vous souhaitiez incarner
l'indépendance l'apport de ce qu'on
appelle parfois la société civile dans
la politique
est ce que ça ne vous gêne pas d'être
rallié à nicolas sarkozy d'avoir quitté
le camp des non-alignés
alors quelle est la situation
on est dans une crise dans ce pays
depuis non seulement la crise financière
que nous connaissons maintenant et qui
ouvre les yeux à tout le monde mais on
est dans une crise dans ce pays depuis
de longues années où déjà l'endettement
est tout à fait extravagant et
deuxièmement ou les systèmes sont
rouillé et vieilli et où plusieurs
gouvernements se sont cassé les dents
aux réformes je ne citerai que pour
mémoire la chute épouvantable du
gouvernement socialiste dans les années
90 93
et puis le choc et le refus et je dirais
le rejet de la politique d'alain juppé
vaut tout le monde a en mémoire les
grandes manifestations de 95 ceci
témoigne surtout du fait que notre pays
n'a pas trouvé l'accord social et je
dirais le tempo non plus pour rénover
ces structures qui sont absolument
nécessaires
c'est ça que j'ai voulu faire en
soutenant et la politique de réforme du
président de la république on peut avoir
dans bien des cas d'ailleurs ses propres
réserves l'essentiel n'est pas là
l'essentiel est de voir un pays au bord
de la très grosse difficulté il n'y a
que deux attitudes chanter les louanges
de la crise en attendant tous cas sa
figure pour quelques-uns qui espère
récupérer les morceaux ça n'arrivera
d'ailleurs pas comme ça ça ne se passe
jamais comme ça où donner un coup de
main là où il faut lui donner un coup de
main c'est ce que j'ai choisi donc
compris un char marie cavada sarkozyste
aujourd'hui où c'est plus complexe que
ça c'est plus complexe mais moi j'ai une
sur le plan du courage des réformes de
l'homme et de l'équipe je n'ai aucune
restriction après les solutions sont
bonnes elles sont moins bonnes personne
ne fait de la perfection mais par dessus
tout moi ce qui me fait peur c'est là le
très grand le commander l'âge le très
grand désordre dans lequel vit notre
pays depuis de longues années depuis
presque une vingtaine d'années on
évoquer quelques aspects on va fêter
l'actualité de la semaine avec à la une
lundi les dangers de la vie à crédit
oui la semaine commence avec christine
lagarde qui veut limiter les dégâts
causés par les crédits revolving et
autres prêts à la consommation trop
accessible pour être totalement honnête
informer les emprunteurs et mieux
vérifier leur niveau d'endettement c'est
le principe de ce nouveau projet de loi
que la ministre de l'économie a présenté
en début de semaine
julia le caureq limiter les abus sans
étouffer le crédit à la consommation
c'est le but de l'avant projet de loi
présenté par christine lagarde
le texte prévoit de laisser plus de
temps aux clients pour se rétracter
après la signature d'un crédit
la période passant de 7 jours à 14 jours
les sociétés de crédit devront mieux
enquêter sur leurs clients
autre point clé du texte la ministre de
l'économie s'engage à réformer la
publicité il faut en particulier que les
consommateurs comprennent à quelles
conditions ils entrent en crédit
consommation et je veux de ce point de
vue qu'un exemple précis qui sera le
même sur toutes les publicités figurer
indique le taux les mensualités et la
durée du crédit consommation
je veux également que figurent sur les
publicités une mention très clair très
précises qui dira un crédit ça engage un
crédit ça se rembourse un esprit de
transparence qui devrait aussi concerner
les cartes de fidélité
mais le gouvernement n'a toujours pas
tranché et les associations de
consommateurs maintiennent donc la
pression
il suffit pas d'informer le consommateur
il faut qu'ils ne soient pas dans
l'obligation s'il veut un avantage
d'avoir un crédit revolving
on vous fait un cadeau mais vous avez ce
cadeau que si vous avez crédit revolving
ça ça devrait être interdit et je n'ai
pas entendu christine lagarde dire qu'on
allait vers cette voie
et ça je le regrette profondément le
projet de loi sera présenté en conseil
des
le 15 avril lundi également la tva à 5,5
dans la restauration elle est confirmée
par nicolas sarkozy qui reçoit les
artisans mais il ya des conditions le
chef de l'état demande à la profession
de faire des efforts sur les prix et sur
l'emploi
jean marie cavada ça c'est un accord
européen qui l'a permis il a fallu un
feu vert de l'allemagne mais une
bataille de quatre ans oui c'était
vraiment le moment de l'impression
classe et on donne quelque chose à un
lobby alors vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure les problèmes sont plus vastes
ah non mais alors l'iphone on va pas
bouder son plaisir je pense que dans
l'est dans les activités de services et
notamment la restauration les industries
hôtelières
c'est une mesure qui est très bienvenue
mais sous conditions je partage un peu
l'avis du responsable de que choisir il
faut tu es de l'état est fondée il a des
timidités de jeune fille il est fondé à
avoir des exigences plus fortes parce
qu'il s'agit au fond de concession de
crédits publics d'une certaine manière
et en tout halal de crédit à la fois
nationaux et européens la tva est une
ressource qui sert plusieurs formes
d'état et deuxièmement je pense que dans
cette affaire-là
il faut naturellement qu'on ait des
garanties d'une manière ou d'une autre
soient sur l'emploi soit sur la facture
l'addition du consommateur soit un
déficit oui bien sûr pour qu'il y est un
résultat ça n'est pas fait là non plus
pour qu'il y ait de petites spéculation
dans les coins vous l'avez dit c'est un
combat de quatre ans certains y voient
le la manifestation du fameux
volontarisme sarkozyste vous êtes aux
premières loges en europe ce
volontarisme là où le personnage de
nicolas sarkozy il facile où il agace
écoutez c'est votre question est tout à
fait est tout à fait d'actualité parce
que ça s'écrit beaucoup je vous dirais
moi un peu peu importe je crois d'abord
que pendant la présidence française pour
être sérieux ne pas échapper à votre
question il a quand même assez fasciné
j'ai le souvenir que à deux reprises
l'opposition socialiste européennes le
ps ne l'a applaudi dont une fois debout
ce qui n'est quand même pas rien et
franchement on peut pas dire qu'il est
été gâté par les événements
la georgie le pétrole la crise
financière
depuis et à cri est depuis dans la crise
il ne peut plus jouer le même rôle
puisque depuis le 1er janvier il n'a
plus l'autorité de présidence de l'union
pour autant ils ne sont pas immobile et
c'est tant mieux
je pense que à la fois son volontarisme
agace une diplomatie européenne 13
habitué aux convenances c'est d'ailleurs
son malheur c'est ça qui ne va pas et
qui deuxièmement il y en a un certain
nombre qui sont bien contents qu'il y
est un président ou ce serait la
chancelière se serait aussi bien qu'ils
fassent le boulot qu'eux mêmes n'ose pas
entreprendre
l'europe a besoin de tout sauf de la
nonchalance jolie formule aller-retour
en france maintenant et à l'assemblée
nationale s'est passé un peu inaperçu
mais c'était cette semaine pour entrer
en vigueur les nouveaux pouvoirs confiés
aux parlementaires par la réforme
constitutionnelle de l'été dernier avec
notamment pour les députés et les
sénateurs la possibilité de déposer
davantage de propositions de loi alors
pour l'instant vous allez voir ce n'est
pas très concluant à l'assemblée à
droite comme à gauche il ya un peu de
retard à l'allumage anezho battions
cette première semaine d'initiative
parlementaire c'est un peu un rendez
vous manqué le patron des députés ump
n'a réussi à dénicher qu'une seule
petite proposition de loi elle est
signée chantal brunel et traite de
l'accès au crédit des pme une seule
proposition de loi expédiés en une
soirée le champ livre est laissé au
gouvernement
au programme donc de cette semaine
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
rectificative les députés manque de
textes en magasin certains se plaignent
également du manque de moyens il
voudrait par exemple des aides
juridiques pour les aider à boucler
correctement leur proposition de loi une
fois mieux épauler les députés ne
devraient pas tarder à présenter
plusieurs textes les idées ne manquent
pas
position de droit ces deux par rapport
aux relations internationales
comment contrôler le ministère des
affaires étrangères j'ai établi dès le
quai d'orsay en particulier un qui me
fait grincer des dents
le travail sur lequel on a commencé à
trappes lanchais c'est l'emploi et donc
on veut des mesures qu'ils soient très
pratique pour permettre à l'économie de
se développer et que l'économie puisse
continuer à créer de l'emploi dans une
période difficile
vous serez prêt à temps oui cap sur
l'emploi pour les députés ump s'ils
veulent examiner leur proposition de loi
en avril
ils devront la déposer au plus tard la
semaine prochaine
côté ps les députés ont dû décliner
l'offre de la journée du 19 mars
eux aussi par manque de temps n'avez pas
de proposition de loi à examiner ce sera
chose faite le mois prochain
suppression du bouclier fiscal encadrer
la rémunération des dirigeants par
exemple conditionner les aides publiques
aux entreprises à la négociation
salariale au maintien et aux créations
d'emploi et la formation professionnelle
de ces trois thèmes qui sont dans le
contenu dans notre dans nos propositions
de loi l'opposition ne dispose que d'une
seule journée d'initiative parlementaire
la prochaine est programmée le 30 avril
très honnêtement cette journée j'en
attends pas grand chose j'attends
beaucoup plus des moyens qu'on me
permettra d'avoir pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement parce que là je
pense qu'il ya un vrai travail à faire
puisque aujourd'hui une loi est votée on
considère qu'elle est appliquée nous on
veut vérifier qu'elle est appliquée ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas et quand
elle est appliquée ce que c'était une
bonne loi c'est une question toute
simple
votons nous de bonnes lois les
dispositions exactes de cette semaine de
contrôle sont encore à définir
majorité et opposition n'arrivent pas à
se mettre d'accord il faudra faire vite
elle est programmée du 23 au 29 mars
benjamin carré d'as avec vous vous
connaissez plutôt de parlementarisme
européen mais ses députés qu'il n'arrive
pas finalement totalement à profiter de
leur nouveau pouvoir ça vous inspire
quel commentaire assez mignon c'est un
côté c'est un côté jeune fille est
farouche est assez sympathique parce que
j'ai vécu la même chose au parlement
européen quand il ya une première
extension des pouvoirs
il faut un certain temps pour s'habituer
à prendre ses responsabilités offensives
par exemple quand dans ma commission des
libertés civiles que je préside et à
l'époque on a
revue un texte devant la cour de justice
évidemment tout le monde était effrayée
nous disait qu'il fallait pas le faire
évidemment on a eu raison de le faire
puisque la cour nous a donné raison il
aurait pu repartir sur des bases
nouvelles
je veux dire que la libération qui prend
c'est exactement ce que les adolescents
voilà c'est la crise d'adolescence du
parlement est objectivement il ya une
deuxième chose que je veux dire le temps
de parole n'a rien à voir avec
l'autorité de la parole au parlement
européen
il arrive qu'on vous demande de vous
exprimer en une minute trente deux 3,30
et exceptionnellement quatre minutes et
tout le monde en fait son miel et ça
marche ça n'a rien à voir
et donc si vous voulez c'est moins que
les quelques leçons à donner peut-être
parlementaires non je veux leur dire que
simplement ce qui se joue c'est ce qu'on
en fait aller face à face à l'actualité
de mardi l'otan en débat au parlement
mardi donc le général de gaulle va-t-il
se retourner dans sa tombe et c'est
toute la question puisque c'est le jour
où le gouvernement engage sa
responsabilité sur sa politique
étrangère en général et sur le retour de
la france dans l'otan en particulier
ça fait grincer des dents à gauche mais
aussi à droite et c'est surtout
l'occasion dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée d'un stimulant face à face
entre un actuel et un ancien premier
ministre
anaïs goût battions le résultat était
acquis d'avancé
en engageant la responsabilité du
gouvernement françois fillon n'a pris
aucun risque
israël syrie darfour le premier ministre
est livré un discours général de
politique étrangère la question de
l'otan est abordé bien sûr un simple
ajustement selon lui la france alliée
mais pas vassale fidèle mais insoumise
toujours fraternelle mais jamais
subordonnée voilà la nature de notre
relation avec l'amérique la politique
étrangère
c'est une action pour un idéal à travers
des réalités ces réalités sont
changeantes et dès lors rien n'est plus
contre-productif et rien n'est plus
dangereux que de sacraliser le statu quo
face à françois fillon c'est un laurent
fabius en grande forme qui s'exprime
pour l'ancien premier ministre
socialiste une chose est sûre la france
risque de perdre son indépendance au
profit des américains
vous nous dites et le président de la
république aussi vous nous dites mais
cette décision va nous apporter un plus
nous pensons que c'est illusoire vous le
dit il n'y a aucun risque
nous pensons qu'il ya des risques vous
nous dites ce sera autant d'indépendance
et ce sera plus d'affluence
nous vous mettons en garde les voix
discordantes s'élèvent également dans la
majorité
les gaullistes certains chiraquien était
tenté de voter contre mais voter contre
aujourd'hui qui vaut à voter contre leur
gouvernement
impossible alors tout en diplomatie ses
députés réfractaires expliquent pourquoi
ils sont contre la réintégration de la
france dans le commandement intégré de
l'otan
quels avantages allons nous tirer de
cette perte d'originalité et de
singularité puisque nous pesons déjà si
lourd et que toutes les décisions
justement s'y prennent à l'unanimité
de quelle influence supplémentaire
allons-nous disposer françois baroin le
protégé de l'ancien président jacques
chirac renouvelle malgré tout sa
confiance au gouvernement de françois
fillon
mais conclut la confiance n'efface pas
les regrets comme le parti socialiste il
déplore l'effacement de la défense
européenne au profit de l'otan et
demande qu'un rapport annuel du
gouvernement sur cette question soit
rendu au parlement et en marge du débat
dans l'hémicycle lui-même une réaction
virulente celle de françois bayrou il
écoute il ya beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels
on peut corriger des choses au moment
d'une alternance l'engagement de la
france dans le commandement intégré de
l'otan
c'est pas un claquement de doigts qui
peut le corriger parce que on a échangé
des plans militaires des en est instauré
des systèmes de commandement et donc la
responsabilité du gouvernement est très
lourdement engagée sur ce sujet et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il faut voter
contre je considère que la france
abandonne là quelque chose d'infiniment
précieux qui était le signe de son
indépendance la france abandonne tel un
signe de son indépendance sur maritima
d'un je crois que c'est une question il
faut prendre les arguments des
contradicteurs ou des adversaires
politiques quelles que soient parfois
leurs motifs à ils ne sont pas tous du
niveau de la géopolitique internationale
on le sait bien il faudrait les prendre
au sérieux
en réalité nous verrons s'il ya des
avantages importants
à la lumière des premières interventions
ou des premières négociations politiques
pour intervenir dans l'otan on verra par
exemple si je l'espère que non mais ça
peut toujours arriver une situation
identique à l'irak se reproduit quel est
le poids que les commandements qui nous
serait qu'on nous a promis qu'il ne
serait attribuée pourront exercer pour
je dirais modifié ne pas empêcher ce
intervention cette intervention ou
quelque chose de ce genre
pour le reste je veux souligner quelques
contradictions il me semble que les
toute la mouvance socialiste pendant
très longtemps avec de vrais arguments
d'ailleurs souhaitait la réintégration
de l'otan y compris pour françois
mitterrand jusque et y compris en 78 par
conséquent à la veille à trois ans de la
présidentielle et de son arrivée à
l'elysée donc il y un changement là
qu'on nous motive parce que le mur est
tombé mais il ya d'autres murs et à mon
avis d'ailleurs plus dangereux
probablement parce que la frontière de
l'adversité n'est pas délimitée elle est
partout il y as pour les centristes la
vieille vocation de genre de canut et
j'entendais tout à l'heure monsieur
bayrou dire que en effet il n'acceptait
pas cette décision alors ça veut dire
que brutalement cette famille est
devenue je dirais plus ardente pour
fleurir les mânes du général de gaulle
qu'elle ne le fut pour servir sa
politique
c'est pourquoi je ne crois pas trop tout
ça il ya des risques à voir que cette
décision et nous verrons lors de la
première question de fond si oui ou non
nous avons des bénéfices réels puisque
vous parlez de monsieur bayrou comme
vous dites votre ancien ami la petite
musique bayrouiste à l'as
blé ou ailleurs à laquelle impact sur
l'opinion par temps de crise aujourd'hui
ce qu'en dit gratuit gauche était député
moi j'ai quitté la sphère bayrou parce
que je trouve qu'elle spéculent sur la
ruine du pays et qu'elle attend que ça
se casse la figure pour améliorer ses
chances d'arriver au pouvoir je ne
supporte pas ça j'étais très déçu par
l'inaction lors de la présidentielle que
nous avons vu et par conséquent je ne
veux pas être de ceux encore une fois
qu'ils sont au bord de la rivière en
disant un cadavre de cadrage trois
cadavres sanglants
je suis de cendres oui c'est trop c'est
trop dangereux pour nous tous oui c'est
une c'est une position de cassandre un
peu en effet mes genoux il a sans doute
ils ont sans doute d'autres méritent le
4 personnes ne m'intéresse plus et me la
stratégie de cet ensemble de cette
mouvance est encore à définir
pour l'instant elle à changer d'alliance
et ça même si je comprends très bien
tactiquement le bénéfice on n'est pas là
pour faire de la tactique
on est là pour aider un pays qui est au
bord de la ruine à se redresser et ce
serait une entreprise de plusieurs
années à mon avis il faudra bien des
concours
ce gouvernement n'y suffira sans doute
pas allez je reviens maintenant à ce qui
a été le grand feuilleton de la semaine
à l'assemblée nationale l'amendement de
pierre méhaignerie à l'occasion du
collectif budgétaire
le président de la commission des
affaires sociales a quelque peu agacé
irriter ses amis de l'ump en proposant
de revenir sur certaines dispositions du
bouclier fiscal
de quoi relancer un éternel débat qui
était jusque là l'apanage de la gauche
faut-il faire payer les riches
le récit avec chloé buffard défendre le
bouclier fiscal face à la gauche
le gouvernement a l'habitude allez vous
revenir sur ces cadeaux fiscaux allez
vous supprimer le bouclier fiscal a
question directe réponse directe non
bien sûr que non monsieur le bouclier
fiscal monsieur le député contrairement
à ce que vous croyez
c'est tout simplement une mesure de
justice je le redis
et en réalité peut-être vous dites que
c'est du culot moi je vous dit que votre
manière de poser votre question c'est de
la gesticulation purée ça plus difficile
de faire face à une fronde d'une partie
de sa majorité la tendance centriste
pierre méhaignerie défendra un
amendement au collectif budgétaire qui
prévoit de créer une nouvelle tranche
d'impôt pour les plus riches
objectif plus de justice sociale en
cette période de crise s'il y a plafond
à 50 % des revenus
il doit aussi avoir à plancher parce
qu'il y a des bonus aujourd'hui ediri
numération excessive qui sont
particulièrement choquant dans la crise
actuelle
donc le débat est ouvert chacun doit
respecter les positions des autres mais
moi je dis si ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
c'est dans les mois à venir dans le
prochain débat budgétaire directe encore
rené couanau réclame la suppression pure
et simple du bouclier fiscal
pourquoi faire tout ce drame toute cette
cette affaire autour de quelque chose
qui finalement sur le plan financier est
à 6 min mais qui sur le plan symbolique
brevets d'un côté un aspect très fort et
si on le suspend des remettrait aussi
revêtir est aussi un aspect symbolique
important un débat mal venue pour la
majorité en cette période de crise et de
tensions sociales alors dès la sortie de
la réunion du groupe ump jean françois
copé rappelle ses troupes à l'ordre
je reconnais c'est beaucoup moins à la
mode que de dire allez on va faire payer
les riches mais en même temps mais voilà
il faut avoir l'esprit de responsabilité
et aujourd'hui les riches paient déjà
beaucoup d'impôts et je pense qu'il ya
un moment où si l'on paie trop bas ils
vont repartir à nouveau
crise ou pas crise pas question de
toucher au bouclier fiscal mesure
symbole du début de mandat de nicolas
sarkozy
voilà jutzet twitter c'est un véritable
feuilleton puisque cet amendement
méhaignerie a été adopté en commission
des lois puis bien sûr rejeté dans
l'émission qui dans cette histoire
alors d'abord il faut savoir quelle est
la nature du problème la nature du
problème au fond et les simples c est ce
que les mesures de relance qui ont été
dans un premier plan présenté à
l'opinion et qui sont en train d'être
accélérée dans leurs mises en place
actuellement des rangs se demande
pourquoi fo les accélérer par parenthèse
si on les présente elles doivent rentrer
tout de suite en fonction
eh bien ces mesures de relance elles
sont ressenties par beaucoup comme
insuffisante alors il ya deux niveaux à
six femmes
la première est l'être c'est un niveau
européen je suis très étonné que dans
notre pays y compris dans cette
assemblée il n'y ait pas un débat sur
cette affaire car quand même qu'est ce
que nous avons vu à l'automne dernier
nous avons vu des tentatives de plans
européens un plan communautaire n'est ce
pas décider ensemble qui s'applique à
tout le monde selon d'ailleurs des
modalités différentes parce qu'on n'a
pas tous dans la même situation
économique n'est un plan communautaire
ce plan communautaire on a vu plusieurs
partenaires faire la fine bouche
l'allemagne je rappelle qu'il n'est pas
un des moindres qui ne voulaient pas
pour les bandes puis ensuite pour
l'industrie automobile et quelques mois
plus tard on a aidé à sauver une banque
en la nationalisant quasiment et
deuxièmement il ya un plan daide alors
provient non non premièrement il faut un
emprunt communautaire pour un certain
nombre de secteurs que nous ne voulons
pas abandonner pour deux raisons sur
ceux des technologies et surtout source
d'emploi qu'on ne peut pas laisser
tomber
la deuxième chose il faut un emprunt
communautaire garantie par l'union pour
autre chose c'est-à-dire les
technologies l'éducation et je dirais
toute l'industrie qui vient derrière le
développement durable il faudrait un
emprunt communautaire garantie par
l'union et les états de l'ue sur le plan
français maintenant je viens et sans le
bouclier fiscal et sur le bouclier
fiscal le bouclier fiscal est quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui est ultra sensible
pour une raison simple on a appris tout
d'un coup que 384 contribuer à l'entrée
guillemets ils sont quatrièmes en effet
avait reçu en remboursement la moyenne 2
338 milles euros par contribuable alors
que naturellement un temps qui courent
c'est con parce qu'on sait que les
contribuables vont être sollicités sur
ce que vous avez dit naturellement que
c'est choquant au meigneux rist je pense
que pierre méhaignerie n'a pas tort mais
il mais il n'est pas dans le bon timing
parce qu'au fond qu'est ce qui se passe
et j'en terminerai par là pour calmer
vos impatiences éventuelles je
terminerai par là c'est que aujourd'hui
j aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas sûrs de
l'ampleur de la relance nécessaire car
nous sommes dans la première partie le
premier semestre si je puis dire de la
crise mais que de toute évidence tous
les gouvernements européens et par
conséquent le gouvernement français
aussi se garde une nouvelle marge de
manoeuvre pour hier j'ai la possibilité
de revenir sur le bouclier fiscal mais
plus tard le bouclier fiscal n'était pas
la plus importante des mesures
d'ailleurs
les parlementaires de nice et pas des
symboles qui vont allier alimenter
l'économie ça alimente seulement la
parlotte donc je veux simplement dire
qu'il faut que le gouvernement est une
marge de manoeuvre supplémentaire vers
le mois de mai probablement avant ou
après les européennes en tout cas parce
que là on verra probablement si ce n'est
le creux j'espère ce sera long mais
c'est peut-être pas sûr de la vague et
des dégâts et qu'il faudra soutenir des
emplois ce moment la une mais sans doute
aussi le bas de la consommation une
autre actualité forte cette semaine dans
un autre style mardi le pape benoît 16
qui déclenché un véritable tollé dans
l'avion qui le conduit en afrique ils
contestent l'efficacité des moyens de
contraception on ne peut combattre le
sida en distribuant des préservatifs ça
aggrave même le phénomène
jamais un pape n'était allé aussi loin
dans la condamnation du préservatif est
ce que comme beaucoup comme presque tout
le monde vous avez été choqué par ses
propos jean marie c'est sûr c'est pire
que choquer je suis stupéfait de
l'inutilité du comportement de ce pape
dans ce domaine où le mieux qu'il puisse
faire sans compter qu on pourrait aider
davantage ce serait de se taire parce
que enfin que l'on soit pour ou contre
je comprends même pas qu'on soit contre
la moitié des dignitaires de l'église en
use en afrique et ailleurs ça suffit
maintenant tout ça mais au moins qu'on
ne contrarie pas les campagnes de santé
qui empêche les gens de mourir à moins
qu'il ait un remède miracle
et si je puis dire en matière de miracle
c'est le moment d'en faire preuve donc
c'était totalement malvenue totalement
contrepoint et puis quand même derrière
tout ça ceux-ci boucle un cycle
totalement détestable de l'organisation
des pouvoirs et de la pensée de cet
papauté ça me fait quand même
cruellement penser en matière de santé
publique pour ne parler que de ça sans
compter les revenants quand même de
négationnisme
un côté pie xii qui ne dit pas les
choses clairement à la satisfaction de
la morale publique et je dirais aussi de
l'autorité évangélique de l'église à
l'est ont passé la journée de mercredi
où l'on reparle du sort réservé aux plus
riches par temps de crise
mercredi donc un nouveau bras de fer sur
les rémunérations des patrons le
gouvernement pose un ultimatum au medef
laurence parisot a quinze jours pour
interdire les bonus aux dirigeants qui
licencient à la veille de la journée de
mobilisation sociale les ministres de
l'économie et du travail met la pression
sur le patronat alain ricci c'est un
véritable ultimatum christine lagarde et
brice hortefeux donne quinze jours au
medef pour supprimer les bonus des
patrons qui licencient laisse hortefeux
et moi même souhaitons simplement que
l'ensemble des organisations patronales
mettent en oeuvre ces recommandations et
nous avons écrit donc au medef en
particulier pour que ce soit fait dans
des délais rapides plus de 36 % du
salaire des grands patrons seraient
ainsi sous surveillance inacceptable en
ces termes pour le medef comment voulez
vous que l'état ou qui que ce soit
fashion la jonction vis-à-vis de du
secteur privé concernant la vie réelle
les organes sociaux de l'entreprise
la vague de suppressions d'emplois mais
une autre question sur la table faut-il
demander le remboursement des aides
publiques aux entreprises qui licencient
l'état les collectivités locales et la
commission européenne verse 65 milliards
d'euros d' aide aux entreprises plus de
trois son dispositif des aides publiques
existent non la réduction de cotisations
des employeurs qui représentent 20
milliards d'euros et l'exonération de
taxe professionnelle qui coûte 8
milliards d'euros alors faire rembourser
les aides publiques aux entreprises qui
licencient c'est plutôt improbable le
problème c'est que il existe un grand
nombre d'entreprises qui sont en
difficulté dans des secteurs difficiles
comme le textile les chaussures etc et
ces entreprises qui licencient
parce qu'elles sont concurrencés par
l'étranger ou parce qu'elles ont plus de
débouchés on peut pas en plus les priver
de toute aide publique parce que ça ce
cas la colle et condamné à la fermeture
immédiate le patronat reste en tout cas
sous pression du gouvernement une
pression qui viendra demain de la rue
alors laurence parisot reste de marbre
parce qu'elle ne veut pas que l'état
encadre des règles qui concernent les
entreprises privées mais vendredi
nicolas sarkozy est revenu à la charge
lors du sommet de bruxelles notamment
après la révélation d'un plan de stock
options à la société générale
vous pensez qu'il faut une loi que
l'état doit se montrer déterminé sur
cette affaire là encore mon rôle dans la
société publique c'est de poser ses
d'entrevoir les bonnes questions celle
de fond quelle est la question de fond
quand des entreprises sont menacés de
faillite qu'elles soient de service les
banques les assurances ou d'industries
l'automobile le rôle de l'état c'est de
soutenir par l'entreprise mais les
emplois que l'entreprise protège par sa
production et sa conseil de la
consommation qui est là lui et donc si
on soutient une entreprise parce qu'elle
est en difficulté c'est pas pour
soutenir l'actionnaire c'est pas pour
soutenir les rémunère
sont des dirigeants et par conséquent on
va dire les choses comme elles font si
monsieur obama lui-même que je ne prends
pas pour un dangereux ultragauchistes
envisage de faire une loi pour limiter
les salaires des entreprises qui ont
recours aux contribuables c'est à dire
quand les entreprises sont bénéficiaires
et vivent de leur propre vie qu'elle
fasse ce que bon leur semble dans le
cadre de la morale général auquel vont
en france cette fois quand je ne sais
pas quand ils vont tendre la main aux
pouvoirs publics comme on voit ce défilé
depuis un long moment dans l'automobile
dans la banque et ailleurs pour aider il
sans doute à juste titre que les emplois
ne soient pas jetés à la rue alors la
première des interdictions c'est que cet
argent ne remonte pas aux actionnaires
les actionnaires ils ont touché de
l'argent pendant les années bénéfique
ils peuvent attendre et la deuxième
c'est que les dirigeants ne se sucrent
pas au passage par conséquent s'il faut
une loi que le gouvernement je lance upi
ne se gêne pas pour la faire
les américains vont le faire pourquoi le
ferait il que la france peut le faire
aussi elle va t'on pas les cinémas si
vous le voulez bien puisque mercredi lé
député socialiste se font une toile à
l'assemblée nationale
projection privée de welcome le film
polémique de philippe lioret au palais
bourbon
un film qui pose en filigrane la
question de la désobéissance civile en
matière d'immigration clandestine le ps
veut ainsi supprimer le délit de
solidarité pour que tout ce qui est d'un
clandestin au nom de l' assistance à
personne en danger ne puisse plus être
pénalisé une proposition de loi sera
prochainement déposée en ce sens et le
ministre de l'immigration eric besson se
dit prêt à ouvrir le débat sur le fond
l'article 622-1 je les dis la semaine
dernière je le redis ici nous est
indispensable pour lutter contre les
passeurs pour lutter contre les filières
d'immigration clandestine je vais vous
dire madame la députée que par ailleurs
il existe un article 622-4 qui exclut
précisément les personnes qui se sont
limitées à porter assistance à des
étrangers en situation de détresse sur
un cadavre de cette mission vous avez
vous étiez globalement d'accord avec la
politique sarkozyste mais peut-être pas
tout est ce que la politique migratoire
du gouvernement précisément vous seriez
peut-être en désaccord au contraire
c'est une des politiques que j'ai
soutenu lorsque
les français préparer la présidence de
l'union c'est à dire ya exactement un an
c'est-à-dire dans le semestre qui a
précédé le 1er juillet et notamment j'ai
beaucoup travaillé auprès du
gouvernement pour faire en sorte que la
politique d'immigration devienne une
politique communautaire et non pas
essentiellement national pourquoi parce
que la politique nationale et
immigration
elle a toujours servi de chiffon rouge
dans les combats électoraux et c'est
comme ça qu'on a eu des extrêmes et
notamment l'extrême droite dans ce pays
par conséquent le paquet le paquet une
migration qui a été décidé par le
conseil de l'union en décembre dernier a
fait progresser vraiment la question est
dans la sphère du débat là haut niveau
français
oui dans la sphère qui nous du débat que
vous que vous citez les deux articles
que cite monsieur besson sont exacts il
ne faut pas qu'une infirmière ou à un
membre d'une association bénévoles qui
aident à manger à soigner ou à héberger
quelqu'un ne soit soin de soi comment
dirais-je exposés à des poursuites
et ça fait le cas en ce moment non le
622-4 dit clairement et en tout cas si
c'est passé que la forêt écrire cet
article
il ne faut pas faire ça en revanche la
dénonciation des réseaux de passeurs est
une oeuvre de salubrité publique puisque
voilà des gens qui s'engraissent de
façon internationale
un des réseaux internationaux sur le
trafic de clandestins et je rappellerai
la phrase de michel rocard faut voir
clair dans cette affaire la france
n'accueillera pas toute la misère du
monde sait les passeurs qui sont dans
cette affaire à surveiller pas ce qui
apporte assistance dans leur ville au
sénat jeudi un consensus se dessine
autour de la réforme des collectivités
territoriales parallèlement à la
commission balladur
une mission du sénat était conduite par
le sénateur ump claude belot sur
l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales ces conclusions commence à
être débattu dans l'hémicycle
l'ambiance est animée mais des points de
convergence se dégage au delà d'ailleurs
des clivages partisans fabrice qu'une et
dans les rangs du sénat une question
fait l'unanimité la création de grandes
métropoles
c'est une des propositions de la mission
belot 5 aussi communauté d'agglomération
pouvoirs élargis
histoire d'être plus compétitive en
europe je suis favorable à la création
pour une raison toute simple c'est
qu'elles existent déjà dans les faits qu
la réforme des collectivités locales
fait débat principal point de désaccord
la mise en place ou non de conseillers
territoriaux comme le souhaitent ses les
parlementaires
de la majorité sion cette proposition
repose sur la conviction qu'il faut des
élus communs pour supprimer la
concurrence entre les deux niveaux de
collectivités et permettent une
véritable clarification des compétences
et une véritable simplification
administrative source d'économie et de
meilleur service rendu aux usagers
le mode d'élection des conseillers
généraux c'est l'un des points
d'interrogation de la mission de l'otan
la mission ne s'est pas mise d'accord à
ce jour sur le mode de scrutin relatives
à l'élection de ses conseillers généraux
entre plusieurs hypothèses
elle n'a pas aujourd'hui arbitre est une
chose est acquise le sénat ne veut pas
supprimer de collectivités locales mais
souhaite une meilleure répartition des
rôles entre elles pour le reste la
mission belot a encore deux mois pour
s'entendre et rendre son rapport
définitif sur cette réforme leur ont pas
ce matin l'actualité de jeudi journée de
grève et surtout journée de manif
oui jeudi de nouveau les cortèges dans
toutes les rues de français les
habituels bataille de chiffres 1,2
million de manifestants selon la police
3 millions selon les syndicats
en tout état de cause une mobilisation
réussie sur fond de crise le public et
le privé ont défilé de concert pierre
bond joseph a suivi pour nous les
cortèges parisiens
elle est venue avec une copine mais il y
avait bien vingt ans qu'elle n'avait pas
manifesté
tout le monde doit être solidaire ess
pompe à la controverse actuellement tous
solidaires comprenez traités sur un pied
d'égalité dans les cortèges
le mot d'ordre revient souvent le
gouvernement aide davantage des
entreprises et pas assez des personnes
touchées par la crise j'ai une vie dame
euros par mois comment voulez-vous l à
350 euros le loyer à payer comment elle
fait comment elle mange à l'achète de
pommes au marché infirmières professeurs
fonctionnaires
cette fois les salariés du privé aussi
sont venus en nombre comme ces ouvriers
sous traitants pour ibm qui craignent
pour l'avenir de 1200 emplois dans
l'industrie du semiconducteur direction
annonce ce cas là des négociations soit
disant avec un projet russe ça fait deux
ans que ça dure ça fait deux ans que les
salariés sont dans la tente donc on paye
mal j'ai aimé le climat social les
dégradations d'un qu'aucune
d'incertitudes sur l'avenir et le risque
du plan social donc voir de la fermeture
totale du site place de la bastille
anne-françoise fait figure d'exception
et lectrices en 2007 de nicolas sarkozy
elle n'a jamais travaillé mais est
inquiète pour l'avenir professionnel de
ses quatre enfants même avoir payé ils
ont touché d'abord en stage mais encore
en stage encore en salivant
m
cette gens puissants
les réponses du dernier sommet social
n'ont visiblement pas apaisé les
craintes des manifestants les syndicats
eux maintiennent la pression mais ce
sommet social débouche sur un
mécontentement plus important qu'avant
c'est donc un problème c'est parce qu'on
n'est pas suffisamment écouté chaque
fois qu'il ya une aide publique
il doit y avoir un engagement de
l'entreprise qui perçoit l'aide en
termes d'emplois l'entreprise ne veut
pas elle n'a pas déplu
en déplacement à bruxelles le président
de la république a dit qu'il comprenait
l'inquiétude des français mais n'a pas
annoncé de nouvelles mesures alors à
matignon on a bien sûr suivi très près
cette journée de mobilisation est à 20
heures sur tf1 françois fillon reste
inflexible pas de nouveaux plans de
relance
il le dit à laurence ferrari est ce que
vous pouvez ce soir annoncé ou pas un
nouveau plan de relance
certainement pas un nouveau plan de
relance madame ferrari moi j'écoute les
français tous les jours ceux qui ont
manifesté aujourd'hui et qui étaient
nombreux et qui expriment une inquiétude
qui est très légitime face à une crise
qui est une crise mondiale une crise
d'une très grande gravité
aujourd'hui la consommation s'effondre
aux etats-unis au japon en
grande-bretagne en espagne
elle tient d'ailleurs plutôt un peu
mieux en france et notre rôle
ça n'est pas d'inventer des conflits
franco français qui n'existe pas c'est
prendre des mesures pour faire en sorte
que la france traverse cette crise vous
avez vu les deux aspects un le säntis ce
conte ce qu'on a vu dans la rue et puis
en même temps on a le sentiment que le
gouvernement minimise un peu ce malaise
social
la vérité c'est que l'europe qui se
pensaient davantage à l'abri du grand
cycle mondial de dépression dans
laquelle nous sommes entrés maintenant
il ne jouera pas qu'on ait touché le
fond au loin de là c'est que l'europe
connaît des soldes des fortunes diverses
si vous étiez espagnol vous seriez
stupéfaits de la rapidité de la
dégradation qui est encore plus
importante que la nôtre
si vous étiez allemand vous seriez terry
a terrorisé par l'ampleur que et qui est
en train de prendre cette dégradation
par conséquent on est dans un système là
où je dirais
nous sommes tous bousculé alors le
redressement est ce qu'on peut dire
comme l'a dit le gouvernement
il n'y a pas de demande de changement de
cap il ya juste de l'inquiétude est ce
que c'est l'homme intelligent de dire
sale le gouvernement utilise ces mots
par rapport à sa propre stratégie
alors qu'il y est une très grande
inquiétude ces inquiétudes c'est tout à
fait vrai je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
d'ailleurs quelque chose de subversif le
on voit bien que maintenant il va
falloir par des systèmes x ou y aider
les plus démunis les très bas salaires
et la pauvreté qui grandit dans la rue
mais il ya déjà des dispositifs il
faudrait il mettre simplement plus
d'argent de ce point de vue là je pense
que l'analyse de martin hirsch et de et
de monsieur besson sont est assez bonne
il faut y aller il faut vraiment essayer
et de monsieur hortefeux est assez bonne
il faut y aller mais il ya quelque chose
qu'il faut comprendre
nous allons encore vivre des mois
d'aggravation du chômage et donc de la
de la pauvreté et en gros j'ai
l'impression que comme d'autres
gouvernements ne le gouvernement
français se réserve un peu de marge de
manoeuvre pour savoir ce qu'il fera en
matière de consommation européenne
gries y avoir une grande claque contre
les gouvernements et contre le
gouvernement français en particulier ça
va se jouer là dessus écoutez si on vote
si l'on vote à l'aune du vent des
démagogues
oui si l'on vote sur la question
sérieuse qui est de restructurer les
entreprises et l'économie européenne
naturellement il s'agira d' autre chose
que des criailleries de l'extrême gauche
d'extrême droite naturellement je le
souhaite parce que c'est sinon ça veut
dire qu'on ne trouvera pas de bonne
solution mais nous allons vivre pendant
au moins n'ont peut-être même davantage
une crise très profonde keira deux
aspects le premier c'est que les
entreprises traditionnelles souffrent on
le voit le deuxième c'est qu'il faudra
mettre en chantier les débouchés de
l'avenir de ce point de vue là tous nos
projets sur le développement durable
sont des opportunités économiques
créatrices d'emplois qu'il faut
fortifiée c'est pourquoi j'appelle une
deuxième fois dans cette émission un
emprunt européen pour les industries du
développement durable là il ya de
l'emploi un gisement
alors justement on va continuer par les
deux robes vous allez être contents
puisque je dis ça ne vous a pas échappé
les dirigeants déjà c'est une passion
peut-être aussi les dirigeants des
vingt-sept sont à bruxelles au menu la
crise toujours bien sûr et la
préparation du prochain sommet du g20
malgré les pressions du fmi et de
washington
pas de nouvelles mesures de relance à
l'échelle européenne en revanche
union est prête à doubler son aide aux
pays de l'est à 50 milliards d'euros
et puis en marge de ce sommet nicolas
sarkozy a commenté le fait que renault
annonce la relocalisation d'une partie
de sa production slovène en clair il a
dit c'est bon pour la france et pas
mauvais pour la slovénie comment vous
comprenez les paroles du chef de l'état
jean marie cavada
c'est une évidence quand même pas qu'ils
aient polémique là-dessus il ya sur wii
bien sûr s'interroge se draper dans
l'est dans les replis d'une vertu que je
ne lui ai pas vus à la commission
européenne de bruxelles pendant le début
de la crise qui en gros courait derrière
la présidence et dont j'attends encore
le plan de relance qui va sauver des
emplois en europe et l'abondement
financier du plan social dont on aurait
bien besoin pour aider les chômeurs en
europe
la commission a été in m alors donc fait
la france là pour nous c'est pas c'est
pas la forme de ses vols au
protectionnisme à quoi sert nous c'est
une entreprise qui n'a pas besoin du
gouvernement pour savoir si elles de
localiser relocalise c'est tout à fait
simple à comprendre
il y as insuffisance de production ah
non pas son double meurtre ce matin il y
à un capacités en souvenir de construire
une chaîne supplémentaire pour
satisfaire la surproduction qui est
demandé on ne peut pas satisfaire la
demande en slovénie mais on a des outils
pour la satisfaire en france c'est le
même groupe
je veux même pas où est le débat points
à 3 il ya des conséquences induites
m'attendais c'est pas une doctrine la
relocalisation ou la délocalisation est
d'accord c'est un débat d'autant plus
stupide que je ne comprends pas tous
ceux qui s'élèvent contre ça ce sont
ceux qui ont crié contre les
délocalisations
un peu de sérieux quand même pas
beaucoup de cohérence selon vous y
rendre on va passer à la journée de
vendredi
la semaine se termine et on essaie de
comprendre la stratégie de communication
de l'exécutif vaste programme
vendredi malgré la tension sociale le
gouvernement déterminé à faire sa pub et
il a entamé dans les quotidiens une
campagne pour expliquer les mesures face
à la crise les mesures du sommet social
une campagne de près de 2 millions
d'euros
on n'est jamais si bien servi que par
soi même alors est ce crédible pour
l'opinion
alain ricci en période de crise
communication de crise c'est le nouveau
slogan du gouvernement pendant dix jours
l'exécutif se paye des encarts
publicitaires dont les journaux pour
vanter les mesures gouvernementales
coût de l'opération 1 million neuf cent
mille euros
quand il ya une attitude qui montrent
qu'une prise de conscience de la crise
mondiale qu'on a dit c'est tragique ça
va changer ça jamais été aussi grave ce
qu'a dit le président sarkozy lui-même
il peut pas deux mois après faire passer
des encarts de publicité ou de
communication publique en disant c'est
pas si grave pour la communication de
crise il ya bien sûr des budgets
débloqués mais surtout des équipes très
fidèle le secrétaire général de l'elysée
claude guéant a fait le ménage fini la
réunion des ministres chaud chaud du
président trop bavard retour aux
fondamentaux avec brice hortefeux le
ministre des affaires sociales xavier
bertrand le secrétaire général de l'ump
et quelques conseillers directe du
président nous sommes confrontés à un
vent de désinformation il est apparu
nécessaire de multiplier les porteurs de
messages le fond du message est toujours
le même mais il ya une diversité de
porter ce qui permet en fonction de la
nature des uns et des autres de leur
style est bien de toucher davantage dans
la population nos concitoyens occuper le
terrain reste le maître mot pour
l'exécutif
et désormais c'est françois fillon qui
est sur le devant de la scène le premier
ministre est un fusible et le président
a vu quittant appelle le président
sarkozy est d'accord et m'envoyer cette
carte puisque depuis le début il a
dévalorisé le rôle du royaume uni s'il
assume toutes les fonctions politiques
gouvernementales et communicationnel le
problème c'est que plus le temps passe
plus mais ne peut pas être complètement
attaquer donc on est typiquement dans un
cas au fait il va vouloir remettre en
selle le premier ministre comme fusible
pour que l'ensemble des critiques ne
l'atteignent pas directement de même le
web n'échappe plus à l'accord
gouvernemental
ministère de la recherche a acheté des
liens sur internet pour contrer les
cyber opposants à la réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur se payer de la
propagande ça ne choque pas le
journaliste que vous êtes resté au fond
écoutez j'ai trop vécu dans les milieux
de la communication pour en connaître
les limites la meilleure communication
c'est une bonne politique
après ça va tout seul deuxièmement je
pense que cette crise va obliger la
présidence de la république à répartir
les rôles et ça c'est une bonne chose il
faut il faudrait pour la stabilité de
nos institutions
il ne faudrait surtout pas que la parole
du président suse parce qu'à ce moment
là même vers l'est aujourd'hui même
temps je ne le pense pas encore en tout
cas j'ai pas les esprits en ce moment à
part les cibles non mais c'est un risque
regardez regardez obama qui après
seulement trois mois de pouvoir même pas
d'ailleurs deux mois de pouvoir plein a
fait jeudi soir de 7 la semaine qui
s'est achevée a fait jeudi soir une
émission c'est un peu comme si la laisse
si sarkozy est allé chez jean pierre
foucault ou chez voyez en deux mois vous
avez quels conseils au présent la
république parle quelques jours une
parole cher et donc faut faire attention
dans les temps de crise de rester je
dirais un recours de confiance c'est
très important après il ya des gens en
dessous pour faire aimer ce sera le mot
de la fin merci beaucoup jean marie
cavada d'être revenu dans parlement
hebdo avec emmanuel on se retrouve bien
sûr vendredi prochain même endroit même
heure à la semaine prochaine
mettre de côté ces différences pour
concrétiser un objectif commun chaque
année cinq détenus de la prison de val
de reuil relève le défi d'un gala de
boxe pas comme les autres à l'otan un
but dans la vie
surtout ça donne un but dans la prison
quand tu arrives là on dit à 10 ans à
faire affaire celle dite nu sur un ring
c'est votre rendez-vous documentaire
aujourd'hui à 18 heures sur la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
changeons d'ère le magazine des
économies d'énergie c'est parti au
sommaire vos conseils malins pour
réduire la consommation énergétique de
la maison jean louis borloo ministre de
l'écologie de l'énergie du développement
durable et de l'aménagement du
territoire reviendra pour nous sur les
enjeux du développement des énergies
renouvelables